so wasn't wrote a review of this film
and they mentioned out loud on Twitter
that dave Franco was wearing socks with
sandals by ow what are those hi my name
is Barry Jenkins I'm the writer director
of deaf villarrica talk and this is my
scene breakdown as far as eating goes I
was thinking I was thinking we could put
a table right here bill Street is a love
story between two characters Tish and
Fani
and in the middle of the film Tish and
Fani like most young lovers are trying
to start a life together they're looking
for a loft although there wasn't a
Craigslist back in the day or Westside
Rentals and the Landlord played by dave
Franco is basically giving them a tour
of the place and so Kiki Lange who plays
to share is very disbelieving that her
man Fani can do what he says he will do
and so he goes well I'll show you
alright hey I know it doesn't look like
much right now but um why did I choose
dave Franco we were location scouting
this building with the real landlord and
the guy came up the stairs and he
reminded me a dave Franco in the book
this characters written to be this very
young Jewish landlord and so I thought
you know what we were gonna cast a
franco in this part because dave Franco
is Jewish I did not tell the landlord
that he looked like dave Franco however
so wouldn't wrote a review of this film
and they mentioned out loud on Twitter
that dave Franco was wearing socks with
his sandals this is because the landlord
of the day was wearing socks with his
sandals so buy out what are those it's a
work in progress
yeah see it's not done it's a work in
progress and I remember reading the book
which is set in the early 1970s just
believing that a guy who's a short-order
cook could look for a loft and
essentially Soho but did the research
and there were all these lofts standing
empty all over the east side and we
found this building never walking in and
kind of aligning myself with the
characters where I thought you cannot
live here this is impossible this was
chipped paint there's rust you might
need a tetanus shot and you go through
the space and then I clicked on
something which was what shows faith
or love or romance more than someone
promising you something that to your
very eyes is impossible and you going
okay I see it
where my mama no go sit you see what I
put a couch right over here in this
moment the camera begins to go around
the room and what I love about this
moment too was Fani sends the camera on
its journey and as we were location
scouting James Laxton myself on the
cinematographer we just started walking
around the space and I don't know I kind
of love it when the experience of
watching a film is as immersive for the
audience as it is for the characters and
so I thought yeah we're gonna take our
camera and we're going to literally go
around at all these spaces and so by the
time the camera comes back to her now
she's all smiles and so it was one of
those moments where have we not location
scouted I don't think this thing with
the swirling camera would have been in
the film you know where the sequence
that just played right there I'm gonna
go back and rewind a little bit
so as this cameras panning around the
room part of the crew is behind the
camera just dancing all around but most
of the crew is right around that corner
if you hit that red door and make a
right
everybody's tucked in and we're all
holding our breath just play praying
that the focus will hit and he comes
back around Kiki's ready and dave is not
like looking at the camera all these
things but this was actually day 2 of
production the reason why we filmed this
so early in production buildings like
this in New York are very rare these
days and even this building was in the
process of being flipped and being
brought up to code and so the only way
the landlord would allow us to shoot is
if we could get in and not alter his
schedule of flipping the building and I
am NOT allowed to tell you the address
of this building hey leave me come on
give me a hand with this regiment I
think sometimes music can have but it
can also clutter and there is a lot of
music in the film but there is no music
and the scene there used to be music in
the scene but now there is not Tish and
fawni are so clearly connected and this
thing we're doing with the camera is so
potent there was no need for it ready
you ready I'm ready three and then we
try to take it one step further we're
fine he's like okay this is ridiculous
now let's make it execute ridiculous oh
okay all right you good yeah
okay careful why am i straining more
than you wishes wardrobe her hair
everything about her characterization in
this film has combination of a few
things one it's a fidelity to the source
material mr. Baldwin wrote this
character is just a very lush and loving
way when we cast Kiki Lane I also was in
love with the way she moved you know the
quality of her skin the quality of her
hair and so when we have visions like
this in these flash outside don't call
them flashbacks because I think memory
is very present those were an extension
of her memory and she's remembering
those things in a very elevated way and
so the light is a little bit different
the the saturation of the color she's
wearing is a little bit different when
we see her
he's more elevated heightened moments
that Tish wants to hold on to so badly
well thank you for my fridge boys but
don't forget about my stove it's really
simple saying but I feel like when I
think of my own personal relationships
or the times where I've experienced
extreme romance in my life usually it's
not like the big thing somebody getting
on their knees with like a diamond ring
you know and a giant stadium what it
really is is these very small moments
when your lover looks at you and smiles
in a certain way and shows you that you
should have faith and they love you guys
are building so do they kiss here no
they don't yeah thank you for watching
the scene breakdown checked out and go
to go talk to someone 14th in theaters
get your tickets on Fandango
[Music]